سلسله من نقاط التحول الحاسمه ادت الى
توجيه اصابع الاتهام الترامب في قضيه
اموال الصمت التي ظلت ميته طيله سبع سنوات
لكنها بدات تاخذ منحا تصاعديا منذ شهر
يناير الماضي القضيه عادت تحت عدسه المجهر
حين قرر مدعي عام من هاتن الفينبراج بناء
قضايا ترامب مجددا واحياء الاتهامات
الموجهه له رغم الاستقالات التي رافقت
مجيئه حيث ان اعاده تشكيل نظام العداله
الجنائيه في منهات سيكون نقطه تحول كبيره
يراهن من خلالها الفين براج على مستقبله
السياسي في القضيه ضد ترامب وفق تقرير
صادر عن نيويورك تايمز غير انه وباعلان
هيئه المحلفين في محكمه نيويورك توجيهات
تهمه جنائيه للترامب تساؤلات كثيره تلوح
في الافق حول النظريه القانونيه الجديده
سيتم اعتمادها في التعامل مع ترامب وهنا
اشارت شبكه
الى ان هذه النقطه تحديدا هي السبب التاخر
في اصدار لائحه الاتهام حيث ان رجال
القانون وجدوا انفسهم امام حاله من الفراغ
القانوني بخصوص الوضع الحالي وهو ما يرجح
التاخر في اصدار لائحه الاتهام التي تنص
على الجرائم المواجهه للترامب لحين ايجاد
مخرج قانوني وهنا يمكن ان يحاول المدعون
العامون استخدام استراتيجيه غير مجربه
سابقا لتبرير توجيه الاتهامات للترامب وفق
خبراء قانونيين